[Music]  coffee 19  spread around the world in weeks and  that leaves little or no time to develop  something new  timely intelligence around the global  spread of infectious diseases  needs to come from better routine  diagnostics and active surveillance  early detection and response are going  to be the key  to prevent the next pandemic so i want  to wake up in the world i want to help  build a world  this is essentially better prepared that  doesn't continue to take calculated  risks but invest in the solutions that  are going to make an  impact this investment is an investment  in our people in our future in our  company and in our security  it's time to implement them now